[موسيقى]
لذا
[موسيقى
] وضعت بالفعل الكتان على الأرض
ولديّ مسمار يمشي في
الكتان وأترك ​​الطلاء ثم لاحظت
تحركًا في دائرة وهو يحرك
الطلاء ويخلق
دائرة جميلة مثالية  بقدميه الصغيرتين
وأصبحت تلك اللوحة
[موسيقى] ،
أردت عمل قطعة تكرم حقًا
ليس الأوكرانيين الذين يسيرون في
الوقت الحالي فحسب ، بل وأيضًا التاريخ الكامل
لأوروبا الشرقية بما في ذلك
خلفيتي من بولندا وأجدادي
[موسيقى] في
بوسطن ديناميكي  المكان الذي أستخدمه في العمل
يُعرف حقًا بأنه أكثر
روبوت مشي تقدمًا في العالم ، لذا فقد كان
محقًا في ذهني مع اتصال فوري
كيف يمكننا استخدام ذلك ،
لذا فهي لوحة حركة ، لذا
يحدث شيء بالفعل أثناء الرسم
هذه هي اللحظة  مرة أخرى في التاريخ أن
شيئًا ما تغير في العالم بأسره
ويمكن لكل شخص القيام بنوع من
الإجراءات التي تساعد قليلاً ، فأنا مجرد
فنان ، لذا فإن ما فعلته هو مجرد
قطعة واحدة ولكن أيضًا يثير الوعي  نيس
[الموسيقى
] وعمومًا هو متفائل جدًا بشأن
التكنولوجيا لأن عملي كله يدور
حول أه التكنولوجيا
أه ومساعدة البشرية
ولهذا السبب كانت هذه القطعة أيضًا
ذات مغزى بالنسبة لي لإظهار
أه روبوت يفعل شيئًا للبشرية لقد
كان ذلك ممتعًا للغاية